[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she's sideways
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh man that's me that's cool
look at that man I have the wolf and all
that does go okey okey okay hey
everybody that's a common one is black
is a black guy and but man don't George
is good he's good guys
solid picture so to watch that that's
yeah we got 6 X 4 RK yeah blue is
sponsor this evening on YouTube playing
the game there ok let's see can anyone
hear me lol Oh check one Charlie Bravo
Dragon fortnight we can hear you yes ok
I was that guy there's AI it's audio
wait yes I think that's your phone cover
this is put together tonight that by
calvin wife tell them what's going on so
tonight we're gonna be playing call of
duty war zone okey it's a three squad
Battle Royale style a first-person
shooter
okey so you're gonna be using this
controller what's your job man you have
to introduce example my name is quarter
by Garrity and I'm gonna be playing with
John key tonight okie sponsor I need to
show we please join us join my club it's
all month this this month is you can you
can join hashtag mug Club use quarantine
code quarantine and you get $30 off all
month
but what bad boy what's that there
when they where'd they go for that they
got a ladder cutter calm swashbuckler
okay I don't know nothing about that but
I know that's okay bye but you need to
show me how that's work like that so so
right now we're in a we're in a team
yeah those three other guys right there
okay
and how do I uh oh jeonggi that's me or
catagen and we're going to do cha-cha
we're gonna do Chet you're doing Chuck
we are doing chest Hey
the serial the internet is not place for
joke there on the chat room no penis
okay no because no no one's want to see
that that's for nobody that's maybe for
you and your Kolak but you're gonna see
about it that's not not for a guy like
that how do I make my guy a Canadian key
my dad's make sense because they're not
going into war for no reason like
American vote Bernie because no more of
that is scoreless so mm-hmm you're gonna
use the right trigger here that's are
you gonna make the shoes okay shoot
the other guys call us what can they see
me play the game they can see my UK let
me know in the chats if you can see my
my screen and that's whenever you're
ready van hey hey hey hey I came out of
my mother already alright so when you're
ready hit that I'm gonna jump in I'm
gonna be other a but am I supposed to
we're just the guide the Peter Pan with
the you net there or am I talking with
that guy from Europe yes we do have he's
on the team yes name is David Baca not
Aki that's cool that's guy look at them
tough guy with the big beard
oh look at
man I sit here with my beard and Europe
and oh I'm cool that's not cool man
oh that's right my cigarette man thanks
man now this is Kali say it's make the
joke with camel noise see never and in
my life people so mr. day that died no
glare or you can hear me ma'am can you
hear me
that's it man I can hear you that's the
first time I played the game Call of do
a Call of Duty and you're gonna show me
and listen I have to say after at Super
Mario man I was hazed for that so you're
gonna see about it
so go girl then hey man hi are you speak
English
yeah very good English bye I don't move
okay you ever play with the person from
Quebec before man yeah yeah I've
actually been to Quebec
oh man and and we kick you out don't
come back as that that's it that was
tough to get in burrows easier to get
out a man your voices you sound a bit
funny you were you have covered
something man
yeah I could have I could have it I
don't know Oh
tested well that's it man hey hey hey
everybody in the chats stay at up at
home okey that's no that's that's no
joke there is nothing funny about
Chinese people eating that's okay no
more of that no no that's it man so
you're going to show me as man that's a
that's a far place away from from Mario
to with a the onion and turnip SC okay
you show me what I'm gonna do man and
I'll try not to make you to wear
embarrass you know oh no you'll
embarrass yourself not me
Oh big word big word for a man who's
come from a country whose export is
is making get get drunk and driving on
the wrong side of the road this see but
show me will ridge the gap right now
will put aside our differences and you
can will be tolerant okay that's it okay
alright just someone's gotta start the
game bat roaring you junkie okay yeah
and I press he fly press he on blood yes
sir lot money sake everyone I'm pressing
here feet that's guys have a skeleton on
the mask are you picked plunders really
I don't know what's that man I pick hey
man you're gonna learn I says well
they're not there no girl you're not
gonna play no more
hey one thing you learn about me man
I made the rules and you know what man
cuz you you gonna know my name okay
I thought you're gonna be mustache guy
yeah that's what I'll call you mustache
man you wish you could grow mustache
like that
hi hey man everyone see that guy from
Harlem the mascara on the the beard er
we all know what's happened like that no
no we don't want to talk about that my
life I've man I'm playing a joke man
that's going that's that's cool let's
look really cool so now I'm there I'm
the a ho right now yeah right now man
it's shown you how to play because we're
watching a cinematic right now Jen Psaki
it's the first time you lose on yeah
you're gonna press start quit and you're
gonna take us all out and do battle
royale hi Garrett you said we're doing
blood more nice for that for it oughta
be easier for you Johnny
for by I'm an easy is not my middle name
it's dying it's it's it's B is what I'm
play more more hard but let's play this
for a little bit manager hard guy later
new
it's there that's not my name that'll
not my name man
a junkie currently and then I have a
that's come from a long line of Acadian
in québécois and Jakarta was man my
great-great-great granduncle you're
gonna see about it so now I press yeah
we're just waiting for Lord the level
you want to back out we want back out
and do Petrella well hey man keep your
underwear of women keep your panties on
your face and don't make don't get not
cool man jeonggi could you be little be
a little nicer green screen as well I
can pull out my green screen if you want
no not on the jet that we have we could
have kids here man don't pull out that
man oh oh yeah yeah sorry yeah I don't
know what I was thinking
you know yeah but so you do this you
make money that not oh wow you make
money in the game Aki no I mean in real
life or you are you are you live with
your mother or something yeah yeah I
live in the basement with my mother i
man that's why I always vote from well
then I man in cell I in like a guy who's
not follow a Muslim I equipment expert
as Dwight I'm insulin so yeah Zhang you
just choose one of those
Aki what's like that you use the press
to a nobody a man there's a there on my
screen there's someone someone has a gun
like that yeah well well you should you
should defend yourself more gun but
there before they can use them on my
screen go like now I see another guide
like that yeah shoot a guy okay right
now that's another cinema hi they closed
the cinema man in Quebec what'd you do
now to spread like that they're low
Apollo your green screen gene
hold on man I get it your strategy is to
make me distract but me man I have the
focus of a lot of a tiger civilians
um call this very fold oh there's
there's two but okay there's two like
the guys man I don't know if you know
that there's two button there like that
there's two different but then there's a
lot of buttons dude there's like more
than one okey it's crazy
okey now we're on the playing hair
canada do i do i jump
all right now hold on we're gonna mark
no luckily if you want to mark this spot
we'll drop a key okay we'll go somewhere
nice and easy
hey ma'am
just like your mother is like that's a
joke man that's a joke man that's cool I
can't hurt my feelings oh come on man
you mean gene with your big beard come
on man you don't have you don't have
you're not feeling so you know i
discarded them when i grew this beard
that's it man that's the Aki Aki oh man
look at that look at that the mountain
hey man that's our Canadian and that get
ready drop on me no you can't ski chunky
by look there man that's look like a
slope you know what like mom we know
chunky cut your I'm gonna die uh-oh yeah
there you go Oh chunky you're really far
away where are you I'm in our village
aren't we a man you shoot me like that
Karlis I think my my their controls not
worked or something like that I got it
common wire yes sir
I don't think my remote is working
another I don't we don't have time to no
problems I think it's morning it's
probably working okey you checked your
brain yeah try it again just got
murdered by a guy on a trek OSE man
that's a joke
Oh see I thought hey I
you know it's different than in Quebec
kava and wire black yes joke in
AmeriCorps Harlan there they're still
supposed to be funny at least I know I
tried I tried
oke Oke amen
we're on the same team that's right on
the tree or or you're playing again are
we all here on the same team okie we're
all together okay then that's let's
let's forget you know Europe and all
that [ __ ] you guys let's be friend
man let's be friend the québécois I have
a black a guy who's black and that guy
and I was drunk
we can all be fun yeah I'm quarter black
that's it that's cool man okey okay this
way I died a man I'm sorry that was not
that was not me that's I didn't do that
man I'm not like your I like your little
thing you've got down there you've got
the Canadian flag very proud man quick
quick yeah you've got a Canadian flag as
your as your emblem kind of a park we're
better off not we did the flight beckus
yeah I'm sorry that's the closest I
could get that's all they had was the
claim now you know what closer than that
is a flag of Satanists the only thing
worse then a Canadian not québécois is
an emetic
american and you know the only thing
worse than hey junkie Johnny please is
the higher loom
that's a joke man that's remotes not
work man that's for sure that's no
[ __ ] Frodo the goal here is to get
money dude then put the money somewhere
yeah search some houses or something you
American man you are always about that
that is t-money
capitalist yeah man in that is in the
Disney movie you're the bad guy who's
not
who's his kid you know when he say hey
man I just want to play hockey and you
say no no no mr. cheapens got to go make
monies junkie what's your favorite song
that's true
Disney man I don't want to Disney but I
I still watch a Caillou but Jean you
what is that you Caillou
that's Caillou Caillou like that's
making my all like the top the toddler
show that's it
oh I don't have kid right
I had one but Dad I don't three more
nice but uh they like Caillou so for me
you know why I uh okay I'm a big guy I
like Elvis grotto chickens where am I
going the right way okay I see the skull
up there and uh does that that's it you
see your dad okay yeah yeah that's where
I died and there's two guys on the roof
right there if you're free for free to
shoot them okay hey man I got video on
okay like that do I at that like that I
don't see no nobody oh man these people
not even let let me get our car yes they
don't they don't like you
bang okay that's a man I think it's more
you know when people like that they
don't like them themselves it's clothing
that's it
their problem is in the mirror and
that's not for me to judge
that's for Jesse Chris I was like you're
Georgia no no no no no that's not no
that's that's not cool man
we're gonna be okay better [ __ ]
okay guy I see a green skeleton yes
where somebody died so don't go oh okay
I thought man that was like a prize to
get it innocent a very oke Oke yeah
because I see call it someone should hey
man you can shoot me when I'm in the sky
like that yeah really chichi man I can
tell you that's a game make by American
because they like cheap shot
and friendly-fire a I meant Khan why I
didn't talk about that before you're not
gonna shoot me man
friendly fire like your body trauma a no
I don't there's no friendly fire you're
okay
I wouldn't do that I wouldn't do that
compared you're having tonight junkie
Oh ma'am bye you asked me what beer I
say there's there's only one word for
for beard that's is a back anyone who's
drink beer that's not Labatt Blue is by
Aggie but that's cool man you want to be
gay that's fine man but I'm not gay okay
I'm not so for that I drink Labatt Blue
IO man I collect oh that's my man
quarter black hey a man found you okay
I'm gonna follow you like that and do
what you do because when in the ghetto
do like the corner black dude a staccato
Dada max
man I really think that's remotely a lot
of beggar's can't get him got him
there's a lot of the guy in the roof man
not easy it's not easy
man you guys you both played this game
before I'm doing okay okay ma'am oke oke
now I'm on my pet hair [ __ ] let's just
go find let's go find naga by ot go to
the orange oh he's down never mind he's
down Hey na glow what's your name on
that I don't see no glow you your daddy
Jim military gym it's like my alter ego
like yours I mean oh you don't have one
hey man man hey you know what they say
about he go leave that [ __ ] at the
door man
don't bring it in just like you don't
you don't wear your shoe in the house
you know because you never know
with legal with you stock or liseberg my
shoes or no I'm out not say old be to
give up I'm a I don't quit man another
guy whose make I don't side you my dude
oh I didn't say aye aye I think my my
hem up learn that's not work man I'm a
meeting button nothing is happening man
you didn't crawling on the ground yeah I
know but how do i how do I get up and
make make my big move I was that's part
of the plan man was to go down and then
get up and crack show them who's wrong
with me oh yeah can make it sorry I'm
Karl
yes that's man you know you think that
in 2020 day this machine walk and make a
controller that's work but next year
Xbox too good don't make it so the nog
man can you tell me so what's your story
man you play video game and you're hi
reg yeah that's about it man you
honestly it nail on the head there I
live a beard
I'm an in sell in my mom's basement time
on it man I I'm making joke man but I
understand my III you know my mother I
don't live with my mother she's live
with me because she a problem you know
she's waiting to get her back
Ernie a to get the MRI so she's live
with me and but it's no problem tonight
I said I ma'am man don't use telephone
I'm using Internet so we're cool it's
good a usual relationship with your mom
like that's it a man nah she's the best
but she is I can go to bed
as late as haiwan you know so we
can do that a lot of Independence all
the attendants yeah yeah that's it oh
man hey I got money quarter black you
know what you got that money oh man you
scared me for a second ah yeah I was
going to go like crack yeah
pow don't don't do the ho my god
hey hey dead Nachman what you need man
IIIi got your back at first then I
didn't like you about it but now I think
you're okay I'm gonna come and I I'll
make sure you're you're good man
thank you do hear juggy follow me we're
gonna head to this the piggy bank over
here I don't I'm behind ya man that's
level is so big you know like enough
you'll like you go okay man like you can
go right and then you can go left but
only for small minute you know you can
go left the whole game but here man look
at that look at see coleus look there we
go we got some money a man
you're welcome everybody what did we do
I made your money oh yeah
okay you did okay look it all right all
right we got some chats on screen junkie
if you want to read them they're right
there on the side and is no glue trying
is a man someone read that for me I
can't read that tire I'm still waiting
for my optometrist that I but maybe in
seven months I can do that who's the
Peter Pan Charlie Brown guy with the
unit and there he can read that for me
we'll take a look oke Oke okay yeah
looks good yeah we're gonna bring it
back up then augment since last time you
cry so much like right come on solo
Zhang Zhang Liang Shan Shan finale
what's game you want to play there knock
my calendar right now you've got a
backhoe hit the B button back there
you go no go down and you're gonna hit
Battle Royale I don't want the like a
dog I know I don't want to be hurt again
as well thank you
okie so I got someone we got a chat from
a guy named Cole he says that he he
who's that he says that he would prefer
it if Garrett were to step in for Zhang
Jie bio I don't want to guy like what do
you think he's going to use to to remote
like ski a SeaWorld but talk about it
they can do ski in this game man don't
play don't play [ __ ] on TV you know
that's a joke it is a good point yeah
how's your childhood by mouth you know
that's like most people are just
randomly curious yeah man that's like
most people you know why I grew up
playing hockey
you know when the pond I finished school
at second doctor they're great great the
hate after that man you know who I play
pool for sharking looking for money for
my family you know my my dad
the my parent not married but you know
is is maybe give me one good crack one
time and we're still cool man are you
married
OC man do I look like Anglophone no no
no Quebec we don't we don't do that man
that's not sugar we don't do that are
you you married no what's what what's
his name Stephen that's not right oh man
that's like like like the guy who's
played belong Babylon basket
yeah one of the one of the chance is
asking is junkie did you go to Degrassi
I don't know what that means
oke Oke no no no no that's a sister key
but that's because that's in Canada and
I know why they're saying that is big
you know that the the guy who's make the
buy me drink yeah that that guy isn't
that show and dinner he player he played
riff in a wheelchair yep shot by a gun
and then now like oh it's tough guy so
people said that talk another you watch
the grass seed no no no no no no no
that's for me man i watch majority
vaccine ii and practice lee create and
blue nari
if you ever seen that non blue Nuri
that's a program that's play like 10
o'clock oh man you're missing out man
watch there learn from Eugene okie I see
a green checkmark
yeah you're gonna press the the space
button once we get a few hundred meters
away from that and then you're gonna go
down down and run around pick up stuff
space button
oh yeah there's no space button that
that I don't know what it is a little
button there
okey now like that you put go now yeah
okey okey then look down and then just
go forward okey that's it there's a few
people here but we'll be alright
I know okay be okay if we all line here
together as friends community oh man
I only have a pistol man I don't know
yeah yeah you have to go around picking
up guns but oh yeah you gonna have to
find him man that's not a war crime all
around pick up guns then go to school
you're gonna see about it
that's sick your people are sick in that
country everything is with God all the
time yes yeah someone in the challenge
to know what system you guys are playing
on Windows 95 actually okey and Xbox oh
man I'm in the prime in prison oh no I
mean
then with the corner black guy that's my
worst nightmare man I saw that in a
movie once I'm not gay man don't worry
we can be my best you in here - this is
a really first year a man that's that's
that language you kiss your mother with
that that mouth no CJ I do men all the
time so much with having sex with the
mothers of everyone who's played that
game you know what they call me man they
call me the guy the guy when I when I
show up they say that the guy who's
who's make love to everyone's mother
only he's not love them every mother
even your own mother that's what
everyone means that's pretty general
jeonggi the another Chad says how many
maple how many gallons of maple syrup is
enough again I'm not sure what that
means yeah yes ma'am that's not cool I'm
gonna be in play man we're playing game
I'm saying game with the guy the yeah
that's it Val collar that Mick tear the
butcher that's right the patata neg huh
thank you thank you I appreciate it I
don't appreciate that
yeah no next is the man that's the word
in French hey I mean sends a little - a
little what neg this word in French is
feets all right yeah I guess I'm not
very culture yeah that's not yeah just
go ahead and err on the side of not
saying that m EG p m EG har he in french
ma'am okay yeah but it's it just sounds
like a different word an english word no
that's nice man I'm speaking French yeah
okay we have someone to ask
jeonggi would you recommend wearing a
wolf shirt on a first date
Oh bye man listen I get us that'll up
and the thing about that is like that's
after a great shirt man that's like
that's super cool where did you get
yours but that's not I get it at at an
issue or no no that one that Petzl
Canada with a book
Jurassic Park when the movie is come out
and when I get a full tank you know when
I fill up with value later okay oh of
pet code okay but that's not for
everybody man like only wear that every
month you're ready for that yeah we got
enough cash we can go man I'm doing good
like that all right you're Eugene right
now Vic for earning money amen
I don't need your help man and I'm I'm
I'm honing that's right now ma'am you're
now going coming to you gonna give you
my money
look at that doesn't mean they changed
my name to work it's called me a
spectating but that's not I didn't
change my name like that
coming back where you like it or not
alright
you're a contribute you'll be great okay
man but man I'm uh s-see Collies okey
what's that fly back in the sky is C
okay well do one of the chances this is
like watching my sister play I'm not
sure who he's referring to no no I know
man that's the woman that's I have make
lots of sex with that person
I do yeah I again are you get the the
resemblance it's because I I I have you
know lately with her yeah that's it
it's a 4-man that problems it's a
problem man
they should clean it up it's always on
the brain montañas penis penis and it's
like man I'm more than that someone
else's jeonggi was
that's it yeah like I have more
mountains not right like you hear me
talking like I speak poor Langat qua
long key hmm
yeah you have a lot to say it that's it
a lot worth listening to
Oh God that's a grenade mound way high
that was my grenade called black and you
take it oh come on man don't be the
stereotype and take what's not supposed
to be doing for that I'll take what I
want
it's mine look look Jackie yeah there's
a grenade right here I'll give you this
one I'll give you this one you go decoy
grenade what's that it's a decoy game
what does it you throw it out and people
think you're where that grenade is by
man I don't want that I want a real one
to blow people in the sky oh the third
guy here Oh Johnny you want a gun you
can come up here and get this gun Oh get
rest right here oh man what just
happened down there
jeonggi someone says watching caillou
explains a lot of why you vote Bernie
I don't play ball kid i man there's
nothing funny about Poe JT oh man
okay I disease in effects oh can you
drop your money can you drop your money
quarterblack
yeah it's just a little boy owes a lot
along I'm coming to save that day for
you guy open door oh [ __ ] that's just me
that's me yes my man tell the [ __ ] out
of me too I get amer plates over here as
well quarter black
I'll get you Jean you do whatever you
want man you're a free spirit
hey man that's take one to know one
exactly dude you are glue and I am
rubber and when you may consult I give
your mother my pen this awesome I was
inspiring I was good
I really oh great thank you there knock
down so you're from Harlem and the user
do you while you talk that that the gay
language that the jugular
exactly the gay lick the lick it
happened when what are you shooting at
Jean and what you men are see college
man i manly but you're wearing the
friend like you look like something in
temple more men uh I understand
look at that man you have horn like that
that's not get it man that was not
that's not me man I was me I'm actually
trying to shoot an enemy oke where I'd
wear oh they're really far away another
sniper yes oh if you don't have a sniper
you probably won't see him okey okay man
tell me what you want junkie to do where
you want me to go and I'll get him below
you
yeah they're in the they're in the
building
keep our down he's down I don't see
nobody now huh they're in the other
building next was the other way Jean oh
man you know what happened you just go
in there on your own I did I took him
down there I took one down they were all
still one guy left they were outside and
then they hear the dog he isn't now
houses when they're that I can see and
they say let's go
I uh maybe I'm not sure about it
one man apt for him to go to the window
I kill him I can afford to bring you
back yeah we're we pink right here
Yeah right Carl IV or you're dead man
yeah how do I worry about it we gotta
get money we all be capitalists gotta go
the other way
bang but how how can you do in that game
with with socialism - like - like they
don't have like a 401 cap or something
like that man no I mean okay we're
giving each other money that's it
I guess that works ah Carla snack no no
no got him down let's see hold the
button to give up drug that I never do
that man from someone who says that you
that your superpower is moving gene
going to your French blood and surrender
oh that yeah that's a that's funny but
I'm not French from France sake I'm
French from Quebec and that's different
man we don't surrender we never been in
in the [ __ ] like that never ever burned
we'd never been more because none we
make love we make love and we don't make
me put them before they can fight that's
it yeah and then after they say you know
I know but maybe not for maybe man I'm
not here for fight I'm here just
let's do that one more time and I say
that's man I don't have a home in a
world I have at you know where there's a
lot of mom's a lot of moms that's it and
man the two of you guys they take up a
lot of time for hey man I I'm driving a
truck I actually know your spectating me
driving it but if you want to believe
you're driving it that's fine believe it
that's it
Ireland mr. Irish take credit for the
work of somebody else ma'am that's the
Irish for you that's it
I'm contractually obligated to let you
know to join my club you can use the
promo code quarantine at ladder with
Crider comm / mug Club $30 $30 on
important get free free stuff all this
month drink Labatt Blue yeah I mean you
can do that too but you definitely join
my club junkie you have a promo code for
LaVette blue ah my man that's that's
promote code itself
that's not need me to do promote man oh
yeah like people see that they say I'm
going over these guys that's for you oh
man a mr. Pibb
mr. Charlie Brown Peter Pan I'm busy
driving my truck is I'm gonna run over
these guys just for you ah okay I'm
gonna roll over these guys boom a
reminder miss them someone suggest that
we play a game every time the jeonggi
dies we drink every time Joong Ki gets a
kill you shotgun a beer there you go
that's actually that's a good game bang
the problem this with Bethel is Wow
what's happened to my [ __ ] man yo up man
they got us we got to go into another
game now we did okay we got 24th place
yeah that's pretty good yeah all right
junky hit hit leave game now a key
that's a legal age for you John
are you sure you want to quit
yes yes polo member I love that game
okey well I wasn't too bad that was
alright yes oh man you said you do you
speak that girl that they Gaelic is
really
my name is Gaelic so no teach us a word
phrase in gala King there is a very
common one
Lina googling it it's called hog mejor
you like this one gene you'll use this a
lot like e with mothers okay my home old
behold my home okey it means it means
kiss my ass
bye man a man that useful man if you're
gay that's cool but me I'm not gay man
I know you talk amen I'm not one thing
to to kiss your house man like if that's
your thing I'm sure there's people and
chat they they'll be very happy to do
that man like a judge if you want to
kiss ha sport okay if there was a choice
right between Canada and Ireland Stan
war are you kissing my ass which would
you choose my man that's never happened
because Canada and your people never win
a war that's like in Rocky 3 you both
punch each other and track down like
that right away
oh and then America come in with the gun
like you see there like that and when
get back separation that's it that's all
no more you'll never you'll never pulled
my own I get it you can just say it
alright but it go to battle royale again
go to battle again we're gonna jump back
into his holla how long are we doing
this for Gina until you become
professional professional gamer bank
that's it not my game plan is make you
[ __ ] comfortable a little bit and down or
you're hustling tip it everyone a chance
do you want to you want to put Bank by
bad pass
at all what's that it'd be I know you
don't want to buy that you want it you
want to go back out and go to that rail
hit me again back in okey there you go
junkie yeah right there right that's
that play one time like that then I said
okey
they're just trying to get your money
you guys want to a gay liquor
you want to put money put money and up
the money on what I put money on on that
like I think I have the Barrett trying
to talk about there that's it man that's
it yeah you want to give me money okay
hey man gonna consume 100 is ask you for
a beer no no no no no you're not you're
not doing well man with your with your
you know your long thing on celsa Cole I
don't want you to waste in every junkie
so one of the chats says that Canada has
the greatest sniper program in the world
I didn't know that is that true yeah I
don't know I'm Vic Canada do you think
we should just give you a sniper rifle
in the game in the game and just see
what happens man I'd like that but you
know greedy Irishman is keep for himself
man I'll take rifle sniper I don't know
about Canada but gyeonggi-do you know my
nickname is what's up was the guy who's
very good at making sniper Wow
ya know it is all along that they're all
true second down they're all to the
grade eight they say man taverns like
the Australis Carles
that guy shoot me in the back yeah
that's that's Americans for you let him
have it
let him have him g LM how you really
feel so ma'am how does one come to be in
place like that in Harlan like you lose
your job well what are you talking about
by like my child for you what's your
life like ma'am the the the noggin my
life is fine I didn't lose my job I just
play video games you know life is good
I've got no complaints Bhavana democracy
everything's good but who's a send you
to higher land who sent me to Arlen
that's it I was born there and you stay
yeah yeah by choice
okay ma'am that crazy I know babe what's
that Nana a parrot-like
I'm okay we'll play it I'm eating but
there nothing is that there now play
nice and easy we'll play it nice and
easy okay we go over here will ever will
do better Luton will get into a car I
buy you a sniper will get you a sniper
dad man hey man I don't care what they
see
not all Irish people are drunken thought
that with nothing to offer the world cuz
I know thank you man I say hey man you
never made it Gayla King nah Glenn
because that guy is cool that's honestly
already the best compliment I've ever
gotten
and then there's plenty more where
that's coming I didn't get rid of my
emotions I would have cried lucky
look at that neuron I'm going to land
the parish ship in the 4s to ID for
sniping because me too I can kill two
bird and get stone you know yeah that's
that's a good plan I don't think it's a
good plan
no I think it's a good plan for sure
it's probably best okay you what man
look at that I'm going to wait in the
forest like a man okay ma'am anyone
playing like that come in look fight me
like a man you guys I want to all have
your gun and your NRA I'm right there
you're gonna know my name if you want to
do it like a man you would like a man I
might head over there look like that
bang bang clack clack I had over there
gene if you're offering to do it like a
man like a man that's where I'm in with
my face man
not gala King there's guys here man that
sound like the best day of your life
there's guys here oh yeah oh and when
you go to the bathroom public horn you
can't say that on YouTube
I'm an garepe 1/4 Lancer are we getting
that channel for YouTube
Oh for you yes we're I mean we're
working on it
definitely this guy bothers oh that dog
man how tall are you
oh we got him down let's go nice I'm six
foot four bush yep I have Norwegian
genetics nope I don't believe that get
armor for yourself but we have someone
in the chat asking if how junky prepared
before this is true there's a sniper we
can bring down oh man think that over to
gene hey we're gonna bring you a sniper
okey
bring that to me you're gonna see what's
a pen you're gonna know my name I'll
give you like a booster you have to come
down here gene the center I'm trying I'm
training I'm training man hey you doing
up there quarter I called my wife do i
if I training do if I'm training like
that do I get stronger in the game no
junkie you don't you said that game was
more of the realism that's not in real
life man I do few punches like that
and I paunch it and kick it and you're
gonna see about it man I'm like bash man
the muscle like like a horse you know
right I do that oh you're cut Jean
that's a great story but can you come
down here please
his armor over there for you he also
dropped armor back way long but don't
worry about it I got your back with that
that's Carl yes bang bang back yep
you're gonna give you a sniper Jean
you're gonna be like the greatest player
ever once you get the sniper in your
hands come over to me gotta find a
weapon the job right there man you see
I'm coming to you man but you running
away like another to get to a weapon
alright okey okey okey no more jokin hey
everyone over here
more making fun of mothers there's a key
yeah no more mother jokes come up here
Aki and then then pick up pick up this
okay okay we're pick that up that's a
sniper yeah okay that up and then pick
and then get this
that's ammo for your sniper key and and
that's it that's it you should get a
kill for every bullet you have I don't
okay okay so happy that should be about
40 kills should I go back to the forest
man and snipe from that should we've got
a move yeah I gotta go on a car here
gotta go in a big truck because the
zones coming in but we'll go to we go to
go to a forest man that was nice
that's more calmer you know in the
forest it's man we can all be friend
like that we don't need to shoot all the
time we can go in the forest have party
man because me too man I like to party
yeah jump in the back there we're gonna
go over here
get a load out and get our best weapons
big race junkie someone in the chat
wants to know if your shoulders hurt
from carrying the team I don't know if
that's the thing sarcastic good man how
can I start that carry man that's can
carry people on the the internet that's
true that's not the thing that's like
physical physical cause I don't know who
you have watching but they're not there
so there are six my lab you know six my
lad in the head right guys let's step it
up on the chair
a key there's the quarter blah this is a
nice Drive
I appreciated it for you doing that
because for me man I like to drive man
have a beer you know I like to party
yeah subscribe this is fun that nice
kaneki what kind of car do you drive by
for me man I have m8 or can you drop
some money quarter black quick I have an
87 honey
cam at who that's that's fine that's the
fastest car in longer is C okay no stay
here stay here
fire back in the truck no no no no no
we're going to the Lord oh we're going
to the Lord
we're gonna get our items hey what's
that man okay okay okay
I want you to do something you sick
Rolfie system yeah yeah you sure do come
over come over here I got something to
show you
come over here press press F on this and
right here right right here right no
right more to left more to the left
relax here you want to go here go here
yeah okey come right here now press
press F on that I don't have an F ma'am
well press X there you go Oh didn't you
Dan you died right the junkies on you
died Oh
Karlis that's it that's it man hey man
that's okay I understand - if I'm from
place that speak language of gala King
but I feel that women I feel that way
too if my mother was known all across
Villa mind sorry I thought you were
drunk potatoes lie about their height
and say they're six for now I'm back in
prison
[Music]
all right junkie credit we're gonna
finish this because they put that on
your face you coming back Johnny
dirty dinner
did you want the Freddy right in there
six MyLab the ad all right come back
doctors come back to answers hey man you
think that guy is really like liking
penis or something I don't want him to
get wrong message I'm not gay like
that's cool if he's gay but I just
wanted to know you put the penis in him
that makes you not gay
okey so it's the same thing in Harlem oh
yeah cool it's only it's only gay if you
receive it that's it oh okay I haven't
works you're the receiver not to give
her by men who are always the giver
that's it and that's the thing ma'am I'm
from I'm from from f Quebec socialism I
give so much even give you yogi yogi
could you come to us I am man yeah what
you're way over there lucky like that
am I going yeah yeah you words the
arrows you want to go towards the arrows
okay oh man you're in the truck yep hey
maybe I can land on the truck like
mission impossible only I can take care
of myself I don't need a woman to come
in and beat the the Xinhua that's just
that's a success especially during these
times don't ya now we're really great
they're weapons if I could get your
weapon City Oh which one over go which
one's the best a sniper one you had
before
like that call is don't amen
don't already - well at least I have my
weapon you're trying to run me over with
that truck
I can't run you over the box kills you
I remove them we remove a key let's go
to the nice nice forest up here that's
it man let's go to the forest and party
first
yes maybe do it like men in the forest
that's it and maybe you can call your
mother
and we'll do you know like the end and
track no okay just me
Oh Karlis that truck is enough to jockey
that's okay ma'am
yeah you gonna work what you're gonna
watch out a man I can walk you you need
to put out more shield you need to put
them more shield my guy
Oki put on put on these these things put
on those where are that put it on you I
don't know what button it is for you but
yeah that's what you need to do you're
gonna hold why junkie hold that white
but they put the armor on there you go
no one really frat guys yeah one kill
that's great that's a hundred percent
better than the last its major
improvement amen
it's not always about the destination
it's about the journey and one time man
and in Gatsby I saw journey with with
Chicago numbness see that was a man that
was a party like I'm never gonna forget
about it
what's your favorite journey song now
that's hard but I like hunger pressure
I think it's David Bowie yes
David Bowie in Queens it makes them stop
all stop become so obey Messner hi ma'am
hey guys do you know this everybody is
is everyone is I ding when they see
jayegi here on the roof oh oh oh man
gasps oh yeah that's really bad oh no
you where you stop moving for me like ah
oh no you know you're Dungy yeah junk
you some of the chances that watching
watching you play is like watching Henry
Fonda pick blueberries that a film
reference to it
I mean no I know that guy I know that
guy you know that is talking about Fonda
yeah because ah is his mother is Easy
Rider
you know
the guy from Once Upon a Time in the
West I don't know matter hey hey cough
call my color black where you find that
where you find that that that guide that
Michael J Fox over there with this the
spectacles man I don't I'm not following
what do you mean that guy who I hear in
my in my head oh you're talking about
Wade yeah yeah he's yeah how did you
know I was wearing my Down Vest there's
two guys top level hey hey Wade yeah you
- you speak Gaelic King that guy I
remember I'm sorry my dude all right
ma'am so so who is you guys your guys
think is gonna win the election
Bernie Ernie for sure sake that's
probably a good pic it's gonna turn it
all around
that's it ma'am ma'am fact that blue
Ernie
yep exactly what was gonna happen all
along and you know what ma'am I think
it's important because people you know
they need to know that it's not only for
money not for it all riff articles
there's some serious man news like
Bernie they're cool yeah someone wants
to know who's alive decision if you have
any advice for them life advice
generally junkie ma'am I'm not big
believer in advice because when you make
plan then I find then the plan the plan
is is not always a pen you know so for
me my plan is I like to party
sure and that's party it's a great
giving and giving that's it man giving I
like to party I like it back ma'am yeah
and and that I make sure that is is I'm
come on
ya know I make sure that we like we made
an improvement I make sure that like
three police
you know once a week no like you Marty
everyone has their thing like you used
the word in English like meditated yeah
yeah you guys use that that's worth like
meditated but that can mean in Quebec
like different thing you know like for
some people that's like like meditate
meditation is like something that's
bring you back to your your your middle
you know so for some people that's like
that can be you know like for you the
video game you know or for you like
coffin wire like trying to find your
father and for me my meditation is
cigarette no no my dad Dan Uggla's
mother it's always leave me with the
smile on my face jobs
my mom she's a great woman
jeonggi go ahead and leave you don't
have to tell me that to time man I know
about it and you gotta see about it I'm
and tell your brother my son hello for
me
well a lot of no it'll be news to him
but appreciate it welcome news okay
you're you're a great father
yeah man okay I make good joke you know
but I think that's time now for me I
think
oh man that's scratch that's scratch my
mustache man no no no no hit the
microphone
so man we play the game and that's cool
yeah yeah but I think it's right to make
sure man that's like people understand
what what we're coming from you know
like what it is so we're gonna leave
about it we have to go because YouTube
is where we're making a new for me right
now today
that's it quarter Wireless who's the guy
who put us on the channel today steven
steven crowder we
louder with Crowder leave yeah we have a
club go go join my club use no it's not
supported by little bit blue use promo
code quarantine get their dollars off
all month but what we go now because
that was cool man you know you let me
come and play have sex with your mother
and what but you have to say one thing
like to describe yourself and this time
that's hard like people right now you
know they want to hear from from people
and and feel you know unity you come on
solo unity together so everyone I'll
give you the floor that then again
what's you what is it you could say
anything you know in gala king or hey
hey maybe English well what what's that
for say to to peoples to make them you
know sleep sleep better be better a nice
yeah man honestly honestly it's just all
comes down to the mud club you know just
a mud club if you've got that mug next
you and your nightstand you'd sleep well
at night
ah man that's nice that's nice for you
to true throw a bone to the the poor
black guy that's nice of you man scenic
that's I say this man forgiver I make
fun of that guy but that guy he's take
his time there he could plug make money
capitalism you know talk about this the
country and patate but he do something
for the black guy and we know that the
guy who's and while he's need that help
that support especially in states unite
you know man like where you guys make
the the old railroad that's nice of Dan
Uggla a man quartern white Lou yep say
thank you to the nog
what what's it that you want to say man
I just want to say everybody let's come
together let's join the club quarantine
promo code join it get get you get you
my club oh man you articulate
for me I would say man prison let's stop
let's put the gun down if you want to
find John Keeler you can put in the the
book telephone Johnny calmly in longer
I'm easy to find no gun okie we're gonna
do with that like a man and next time
that I see you guy will do that like a
man because me I like to party you know
and I think right now everyone is pick
pick grab that cough cough no fun but I
think we all need to man have more fun
you know forget politic forget the past
forget you know your father he is not
coming back buying [ __ ] I know my
father a bag man I know he's wrong Wow
word there have a party and do that like
a man a key man we all men and all men
have thing in common we all want to be
to to have to party we all want to be
loved and every man young [ __ ] hole is
having sex with Dana's mother thank you
everybody and you know we'll see you
next time next time we play street
fighter like a man I'm going to go party
okay let's go man party man Hooper mom's
not a quarter black man some lady let's
do the Buddha music
if I tell my mom and she tells you if
she tells you
[Music]
if I tell my mom and she tells your mom
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hope everything turns out okay
[Music]
the money in the cash register
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr. company
[Music]
shirt a TV reporter
[Music]
the money in the cash register
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
mr. company
[Music]